[Music]
invasive species expert Martin Golding
is investigating a startling phenomena
less than 20 years ago England was
completely free of wild boar today
hundreds prowl the forests here but
while Chris Griffin wouldn't face
Hogzilla without a gun Martin's only got
a flashlight which is playing a game of
chance we know they're about as we've
heard them in the distance on one rarely
close up because it makes the hair on
the back of your neck stand up so we're
just gonna walk quietly through the
woods without it open just listening
this is not just a bottle of water this
is a wild boar that has been wallowing
and you can see where the sides down
where the animal is rolled was very well
this is very conspicuous oval-shaped
patch of water over the border rolling
the animal he seeks is the Eurasian wild
boar an ancestor of Hogzilla and perhaps
the close relative
the wild boars returned to britain holds
a sobering lesson hogs have abilities
were just beginning to fathom some form
of pig has walked the earth
for 40 million years their earliest Pig
had a head more than 3 feet long bigger
than the entire body of a grown wild
boar today some prehistoric pigs reached
the size of cows and many had long horn
like protrusions on their heads over
time they evolved into the smaller wild
boars that still roam forests around the
world they may be smaller but today's
wild hogs carry an arsenal of weapons
long tusks tough shoulders like battle
shields long powerful snouts that can
smell an enemy up to 7 miles away
they've got terrifying built-in
armaments but thousands of years ago
wild boar used an even better weapon to
survive their brain when civilization
was young wild boar formed a strategic
relationship and started living with
humans